well just first of all that was North
London forever which is the anthem of my
soccer team Arsenal only used soccer in
America we are currently top of the
Premier League for the first time in 18
years after 18 years of pain and torment
and torture nobody finally will win but
none of your viewers care so I'll move
on to what you do care about Democrats
keep looking for ways to deflect blame
on surging violence in America's streets
out in Los Angeles a homeless man
stabbing a woman in the head with a pair
of scissors and an unprovoked attack
she's now recovering from a traumatic
brain injury and in New York a man was
pushed to his death in front of subway
train after he accidentally bumped into
another Rider and knocked over his cell
phone well the Meredith City Eric Adams
argues that the idea of cities being
unsafe is Just an Illusion
we're dealing with actual crimes those
eight uh homicides and we're dealing
with the perception of fear that people
are feeling that's the combination and I
must deal with that profession
perception in the actual crime we can't
get away from the fact we have 3.5
million people using our subway system
we we have to be honest about that and
those average of six crimes a day is not
given the impression that our system is
out of control
well judge I think delusion may be the
theme of tonight uh this seems to be a
completely deluded about what fear of
crime actually involves you know pierce
the real problem is New Yorkers are
desperate and they voted for that man
because he was a former police captain
and everything that he's that he's done
has been inconsistent with that prior CV
I still want to see this guy with his
sleeves rolled up out there at the scene
of a homicide bad-mouthing Albany for
the for the laws that we have but for
I've seen people blame crime on
circumstances on the pandemic upon
poverty they blame it sometimes on the
criminal sometimes on the victim this
guy's blaming crime on our perception of
whether or not we see it as a crime he's
wrong the stats belie everything that he
says and you know what if the mayor of
New York City is going to get up and
he's going to make a statement about
statistics he ought to be right first of
all crime is up on the subway uh that's
the highest it's been in 25 years and
the people riding the subway now it's
less than half of what it was two years
ago so we've got double triple the crime
with half of the people riding the
subway homelessness is out of control
crime on the subway is out of control
all of us have seen images of women
being raped on a platform of people
being pushed in front of a train of
Asians being beaten at a at a at a
subway station and I'm just talking
about crime on the trains you know damn
it you know every time someone is
injured he wants to talk about
perception why don't you go out there
and deal with the victims and the
reality Greg you were snorting audibly
during what he was saying there I mean
the one stack that was baby powder the
start of the sprang out to me 22 people
would be murdered on the New York subway
since the start of 2020 including eight
this year I don't care what part of the
world you're from if 22 people are
murdered on the subway in two years that
is not a perception issue yeah that is a
reality especially and you can you know
that perception is reality when you
compare it to a previous period of time
and then you see the increase that's how
you come up with Statistics these aren't
just anecdotes the city is a barrel and
we're the fish and I think that's
happening everywhere we had to there was
a promise of this new mayor I think it's
run out I don't think it's entirely his
fault this is the fault of one party
rule there is no resistance when the
brake lines are cut right this is a
single parent household and the single
parent can't take it the kid take care
take care of the kids anymore the Dems
need Republicans or you're going to end
up like Chicago you're going to end up
like NYC Minneapolis Louisville San
Francisco L.A the only way this can work
is if people work together but the
problem is it's there's a certain kind
of new leader this Progressive leader
who doesn't believe that what we are
doing is actually fair that actually Law
and Order is oppression and so you look
at homelessness you look at drug
addiction you look at crime you look at
the border what do they have in common
nothing's being done exactly and when
you talk to these leaders you get the
feeling that that's exactly what they
want so it's like when you're yelling
it's like yeah yeah yeah but you know
what maybe this will come to a head and
we'll be able to remake Society in a
completely different way because
everything sucks so you know the number
one issue burning issue for New Yorkers
right now according to a new poll was
crime yeah even more than inflation I
found that staggering but very
enlightening yes they're both seen with
their own eyes and then making a
decision that there's got to be a change
to what you're saying that may that
perhaps this this is the straw that
breaks the camel's back and maybe gets
some changes I uh friends on both sides
of the aisle that work in political
Consulting believe that Republicans are
going to pick up all of the seats on
Long Island and most of the seats in the
Hudson Valley are probably theirs as
well so that's a that's a that's a big
change but one of the reasons you have a
perception is based on your own two eyes
and it's also based on the thing that
your husband says you're not taking the
subway you're not walking home therefore
you have to leave an hour early because
the traffic is so bad because no one's
on the subway also no one's on the
subway guess what that means that no
one's paying to be on the subway which
means it's going to go bankrupt and then
the federal taxpayers are going to have
to bail out New York City subway system
because there's you have to have a
subway system in the nation's capital
and the inflation border crime issue
like we say about the theme it's really
remarkable
in each of these instances you have
Democrats saying inflation's transitory
is not really happening it's not that
bad the economy's strong as hell what oh
the border is secure what crime is just
your perception but when you're talking
about I just had a nice dinner I just
had a nice dinner there was no crime
yeah right I mean that's the point Jess
isn't it this delusion theme is a
running theme I think of this
Administration and people offered they
just seem to want us to not believe what
we're watching with our own eyes and
hearing with our own ears it is delusion
it is I'm afraid of rats let's say I go
to your castle and during dinner a rat
scurries across my penny loafer now you
could say Jesse the chances of you
getting bitten by a rat are
infinitesimal
I don't care
I want you to set a rat trap and I want
a dead rat that's what the country wants
they want action they don't want to be
explained how in the context this may be
not that big of a deal especially when
it is a big deal imagine during the war
on terror when people were afraid of
domestic Terror attacks Barack Obama or
anybody didn't get out there and say
well you know what the chances of you
dying from a domestic terrorist attack
by ISIS is very very small you could
actually have a better chance of dying
from a car accident no we wanted to kill
terrorists we wanted people to take
action what the leaders now are doing
they're afraid to take action they're
afraid of the consequences of taking out
it's so weird because actually being
tough on crime is a Surefire election
yes especially when people actually have
a perception there's a lot of crime who
are they scared of that's the thing that
that's where you find out where this All
Leads scared of their left-wing base
yeah they'd rather talk away the issue
than take action correct uh just for the
record if you did ever stay in one of my
castles
I wouldn't use rats they're unreliable
I'd use a fox
I need a very big trap for a fox um
anyway good you'd like it the fox gets
the fox you get it I get it you see
where I'm going with that road trip
up next no wonder there's no hope for
the Future these spoiled Generations z z
brats whatever they call themselves so
they actually love cancel culture we'll
be debating that next I want to Brian
kill Mead I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now